an dieser Tankstelle im französischen
Straßburg finden sich auffallend viele
deutsche Autofahrer dadurch herkommen
aus dem Südschwarzwald da kostet jetzt
mittlerweile 40 50 Cent mehr pro Liter
und das merkt man dann schon stark die
niedrigen Preise erklären sich durch
eine Subvention 30 Cent pro Liter
erspart der Staat den Autofahrern und
die Regierung kündigt weitere Hilfen an
wir werden die Preissteigerung beim Gas
auf 15% begrenzen im Januar nächsten
Jahres und auf 15% beim Strom im Februar
niedrige Energiepreise wirken sich auch
bei anderen Produkten aus dank der
umfangreichen staatlichen Hilfen ist die
Inflation für französische Verbraucher
derzeit niedriger als bei den
europäischen Nachbarn
mit 16 Milliarden Euro will die
französische Regierung auch künftig
Energiepreise Deckeln so erkaufte sich
auch soziale Ruhe
im kohle-landpolen fehlt die Kohle Polen
muss zukaufen hier kommen 20.000 Tonnen
aus Südafrika in Swinemünde an und auch
beim Nachbarn wird eingekauft in
Tschechien jeden Tag kommen 50 bis 60
Autos aus Polen zu uns fast jeder zweite
Haushalt in Polen heizt noch mit Kohle
dazu der Industriebedarf bei der
Stromerzeugung werden mehr als 70% aus
Kohle gewonnen aber die immer kleineren
Flötze liegen immer tiefer im Gestein
sind unrentabel und teuer jahrelang
importierte Polen billige Kohle vom
ewigen Feind Russland ausgerechnet
russische Kohle brannte in fast 70
Prozent der polnischen Kohleöfen die
fehlt jetzt tonnenweise seitdem die
polnische Regierung einen Importstopp
verhängte noch vor den EU-weiten
Russland Sanktionen Mangel + Inflation
die Kohlepreise schießen in die Höhe sie
sagten immer wir haben noch für 200
Jahre Kohle aber es gibt keine
Dezember fast leere Lager Massenproteste
allerdings gibt es nicht in der
Bevölkerung sind die Russland Sanktionen
unumstritten
Krisen haben die Niederländer eigentlich
genug da ist erstens die stickstoffkrise
Martin Janssen sagt wir haben kein
Vertrauen mehr in die Politik
weil der Mist der Kühe die Luft belastet
will die Regierung den Bestand
reduzieren aus Protest dagegen wird die
Fahne auf dem Kopf da ist zweitens die
erdgaskrise buluten Harve sagt
wir müssen die Decke Stützen sonst fällt
sie uns auf den Kopf
ringsum Groningen bebt die Erde die
Regierung aber schiebt den Förderstopp
fürs Gas immer weiter hinaus aus Protest
dagegen streicht er die Fassade rosa
dazu kommt nun die kaufkraftkrise die
Inflation liegt in den Niederlanden bei
über 13 Prozent die liberale Regierung
um Marc Rütter hat lange gezögert der
ist jetzt will sie den
mindestlohnerhöhen und die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Energie senken 14
Milliarden Euro beträgt der Hilfspaket
aber die Wirklichkeit ist schon weiter
heute am Prinz ist Tag wird der König
traditionell verlesen was die Regierung
im diktiert das Hilfspaket könnte dabei
um weitere Milliarden wachsen